es gibt schon eine menge menschen die
ganz genau wissen wie sie unser system
ausgegeben einfaches beispiel
handwerksbetriebs steht man an der theke
und sagen ich hätte gern den chef
gesprochen der chef kommt kennen chef
persönlich damit die geschichte erzählt
sagt ich bin nicht mehr zufrieden drüben
bei dem anderen gewerbebetrieb die
anfang er sagt ja kriegten doppelten
fast doppelten stundenlohn wie vorher
nach sechs wochen sucht das gespräch mit
dem unternehmer und sagt sorry ich hätte
gerne einen alten stunde und zurück ich
habe netto jetzt weniger wie vorher
daraufhin sagte unternehmen wie das
mache ich nicht geht bei uns auch nicht
weil haben wir ja gegeben da geht in
krankheit arbeitsgericht er muss noch
eine abfindung zahlen warum weil er sagt
die zugeständnisse nicht vom staat
bekomme also die stützen die ich
gekriegt habe die wahren mehrwert unterm
strich wir jetzt mit dem höheren
stundenlohn und davon gibt es eben auch
beispiele im stadion standen kopf
also wenn es den fall gebe da werde er
nur denkbar solche zurückkehrte für
diese gesetze beim bezug von wohngeld
dass man hier wohne hinzu kommt dann
fällt das kleingeld wird und da achtet
politische aufgabe der politik dafür zu
sorgen dass diese übergänge fließend
sind dass genau das nicht passiert also
der fall wenn er sie ja nicht
geschwindelt hat der betroffene das so
selten dass der oft auch selbst bei
beziehern von hartz 4 jeder hartz 4
bezieher erarbeitet hat immer mehr im
portemonnaie als wenn er nicht arbeitet
geht gar nicht anders ist das bei so gut
wie allen sozialleistungen und deswegen
wenn diese geschichte sich so zugetragen
haben sollte ist sie wirklich ein so
seltener fall den kann man sich einer
weekends beim steuersystem ja genau
anschaue habe ich erst mal mehr in der
tasche ist nicht so als hätte ich
weniger wir haben gerade gehört jemand
kriegt mehr geld und hat weniger ja
höhere
höhere steuer das einzige was hier so
verein das ist das einzige was dann
passieren kann ist dass die preise
weiter steigen und dass man dadurch
weniger kaufkraft hat man hat aber immer
mehr gilt das haben jetzt mal nicht
dieter herm land mich ja auch auf herr
huber die diskussion dahinter ist wir
reden über alle möglichen staatlichen
maßnahmen der neue csu-generalsekretär
martin huber über alle möglichen neuen
staatlichen maßnahmen jetzt über klima
geld energie geld tank rabatt und so
weiter aber richtig ans steuer senken
will keiner ran wäre dass sich der
einfachste weg einfach steuern senken
massiv erklärt steuer zum beispiel eines
abschaffen
zunächst dabei würde mich mal
interessieren was die ampel wirklich
steht weil wenn jede woche oder jeden
tag ein vertreter einer anderen appell
partei durch die talkshows tingelt und
eine andere vorstellung publiziert dann
weiß man immer was sie eigentlich wollen
auch heute haben alle schon erlebt und
wie sie richtig sagen die einfachste
möglichkeit wäre natürlich steuern
senken und vor allem auch ein
belastungsmoratorium für die wirtschaft
wir müssen bürokratie abbauen müssten
vor allem auch die wirtschaft
entsprechend unterstützen eben wie
gesagt noch ein belastungsmoratorium
denn die auflage oft man auch im bereich
der bürokratie müssen jetzt
zurückgefahren werden damit auch wie es
der herr im blick sagt die wirtschaft
wieder lust bekommen zu investieren und
anzupacken denn das ist ja auch das
rückgrat dessen was wir in unserer
gesellschaft haben man blickt nicht so
recht durch all so was wie die ampel
jetzt konkret wie soll die entlastung
aussehen über das was beschlossen ist
hinaus eine senkung auf lebensmittel ist
kein grüner vorschlag er wird auch nicht
zum grünen fordern in dem sie das
behaupten der tatsache ist dass sich
diese ampel mit 2 entlastungs paketen
binnen zwei monaten der größeren von 34
milliarden euro als ausgesprochen
handlungsfähig erwiesen hat da kann man
jetzt auf einzelne komponenten dieser
entlastungspaket unterschiedlich gucken
ich bin über manche ist wirklich sehr
froh
stichwort energie
sozusagen pauschale ich bin mit anderen
weniger glücklich und halte es auch
nicht für wirklich ziel führen wir
werden ja sehen ob dieser sprit rabatt
tatsächlich bei den bei den menschen
ankommt oder nicht das haben wir anfangs
diskutiert das ist doch aber auch gar
nichts ungewöhnlich ist dass mit blick
auf einmal
große entlastungspaket auch
unterschiedlich gerückt werden kann auf
einzelne komponenten dieser pakete
ändert aber nichts an der
handlungsfähigkeit und daran dass diese
koalition
an gehandelt hat und zwar in kurzer zeit
sehr zielgerichtet und überwiegend auch
so dass bei denen ankommt die es am
dringendsten brauchen
das halte ich mal der position zugute
und ansonsten werden wir die
diskussionen weiter fortsetzen und ich
mag an es ist ja kein geheimnis dass in
dieser ampel unterschiedlich guckt wird
auf die frage von steuergerechtigkeit
und damit wir uns nicht falsch verstehen
ich bin kein neoliberaler oder turbo
kapitalist und ich sind auch
gewerkschaften haben ihre berechnung ich
bin auch dafür dass für faire leistung
auf ihrer lohn bezahlt aber auch mehr
leistungen nehmen sie auch noch mal
jetzt das wochenende wenn er gekommen
die autobahnen sind voll wir hatten
wieder seit christi mit sword das land
war wieder leer mir geht es darum dass
wir über meer erst schaufeln dann
scheffel machen ja und das war über eine
steuer wir waren ja mal kurz davor
einfach drei einfache steuergesetze drei
steuersätze alles andere abschaffen boah
was hätten wir für eine tolle entlastung
werden auch nicht mehr soviel band die
das überprüfen